well let's talk about real let's talk
about reality bites back because that's
where you and I first met each other
which is kind of crazy like some people
don't even know about this show and I
wish I don't know if we could put clips
of it into this episode without it
getting taken down dude if I I'll tell
you right now if you could find the clip
of me getting kicked off of reality
bites back yeah do you remember that
Greg Louganis dude great and Michael Ian
Black
yeah do you remember what how I got
kicked off I remember you did like yeah
you were somebody said you did like a
DNA like like a broke chain D like an
HIV kind of DNA hit pants on a desk yeah
I've got there was it so for those who
don't know it's a reality show within a
reality show and I don't know where you
can find it if you can find this clip I
have all the videos at home please send
it to me I would allow it and I'm gonna
make it sound ridiculous this is exactly
what it is so it's me mo mandel and Amy
Schumer on the final table hmm I have
been hitting on Greg Louganis the whole
time as a joke I thought it was like and
he was handsome I mean this is back tell
you by the way can I stop and put a pin
in this your dive in the wheelchair I am
familiar or art was the funniest [ __ ]
thing in the world
thanks man I'll describe it for anyone
who can't see it Theo does this like
song to the judges about Amelia Earhart
makes no sense yeah get to the
wheelchair someone rolled you off
correct someone rolls him off and he
falls I think 25 feet 20 feet onto his
stomach yeah with what I think wings
attached to your wheelchair and and
knocks the wind out of him legit yeah
hops up like and we are all like fooling
me Earhart full of millionaire heart and
everyone's like 10 10 10 it was [ __ ]
amazing and then mo mandel because oh
yeah oh did it Mo's dance Mo's dive
that's the whole thing was so you think
you could dive it's a mix up of so you
think he danced and a diving competition
yeah
mo man tells was making fun of the time
when Gregg hit his head and I even think
he said there's aids in the pool or
something yeah he goes oh man I'm gonna
jump in the pool my hope I don't get get
any aids on me or something then he
jumps and almost hits the diving board
all the [ __ ] [ __ ] head
real unbelievable and he did not plan on
doing that at all I literally came 1/2
inch from hitting his head on the diving
board
yeah and I remember what Amy's dive was
but it was inconsequential yeah because
and mine was everybody else are already
kind of [ __ ] there were so many outliers
that amy losses had to play right in the
middle yeah and and and and Chris
Fairbanks did a double flip yeah and
nobody gave a [ __ ] yeah who does that
get this [ __ ] guy out of here but it
was like every so everybody made so many
poor choices oh and then and then so
then then the whole thing is then that
it turns into the boardroom with Donald
Trump whatever that show The Apprentice
yeah the apprentice they bring us into
the end they bring me Amy mo in and it's
Greg Louganis and Michael Ian Black and
he real quick cruises through MO and
Amy's like mo your dive was a little
offensive Amy it was inconsequential
Bert I understand you're married and I
went I am I think with children and I
said I am and he goes you're not a gay
man and I went no he was like do you
realize how offensive it is to hit on a
gay man and lead him on and make him
think you were gay I was legit hitting
on Greg Louganis the whole [ __ ]
episode like even low-key hitting on him
even when the cameras were off I was
flirting with him thinking like if he
thinks you know whatever right if he
thinks I might be able to [ __ ] my pet
give me an extra you know yeah and he
was like and and I think it was edited
out but I think it the thing I go Greg
you have AIDS I would do you think I was
hitting on you and he was like he was
like you're fired and he just gets up
and leaves and Amy and Mo were like oh
my god they're like what the [ __ ] did
you just witness and then they're like
mo and Amy are dismissed
and they get up and they walk out and
then Michael Ian Black goes Bert you've
made a lot of bad life decisions by the
way he's Mike's the Michael the in
blacks not even joking at this point
right and I was like yeah and he goes
your body your hair I mean your facial
hair like he's picking me apart yeah I'm
like yeah and by the way I no joke I am
humiliated at this moment because I had
driven all of us down remember I drove
us all deaths and in the car ride down
Amy said oh my god what if one of us
gets kicked off how awkward he would the
drive back beat and I was like oh my god
I got to drive everyone [ __ ] home and
so I he goes Michael Ian Black psych oh
I'm gonna need your trunks me your suit
and I was like okay
and so I get up and I'm just embarrassed
and I'm trying to make it funny and I
don't know how to mmm
so I knock over each of the chairs and
he goes what are you doing and I said I
make big exits Michael and he was like
no there's no music playing in this Mike
Lee and blacks yeah I mean really
talented kind of a [ __ ] though but he's
and he's really straight the whole thing
was like straight man
yeah always and I take my robe off and
then I take my trunks off and I'm naked
and he's like wow he's like and he might
be Helmer Rob he's not even joking at
this moment he's like I wouldn't do that
by the way there's a 30 person film crew
there yeah filming this I get on the
table and I put my feet on the back of
his chair and I start pulling his face
into my junk and he's like no no he's
like I could look at it Michael and he
goes I'm afraid I'll turn to stone I go
part of you will yeah and then I don't
know and by the way I'm not winning a
laugh it is awkward it is uncomfortable
at this moment and I look at him and in
the lastest ditch effort I kick and I do
a back spin naked and I stick it on the
table and I look at him and [ __ ]
thank you Michael in black breaks
character and starts laughing
hysterically and the whole set starts
laughing and I walk off now my daughters
were in preschool at the time and I had
only been bragging I will be on Comedy
Central and I know now as I'm driving
you guys back that's all these parents
will see his mean face [ __ ] Michael
Ian Black
yeah oh my god and I tell my wife
neither dad's will be jealous probably I
tell my wife when I get home I she was
headed today to go and I said I think I
might've just ruined my career and she
was like really and so I didn't think
about it until it episode aired and then
Amy called me the day there and I was in
Pittsburgh
wow what did she say she goes I just
watched the episode where you got kicked
off it is [ __ ] hilarious you have
nothing to be worried about it is
[ __ ] hysterical she's like highlight
of the show and I was like oh my god it
was funny and it was funny and then it
disappeared nobody really have AIDS
regular games cuz he is HIV positive I'm
really positive positive yeah yeah do
you think you could be eight
what's a disease you could be name three
diseases you could beat honestly Crohn's
oh no way I think so you couldn't beat
Crohn's can you
Crone's what it is it's just your
stomach hurts a little bit yeah dude if
you're talking about a guy who just like
yeah we're [ __ ] somebody in a deep
freezer eating a [ __ ] snicker and a
40 no no way you're know so you're
talking about being the disease so
you're talking about me getting it and
going I can lick this disease yeah I
could be Crohn's it's right around the
butt it's like irritable bowel syndrome
almost yeah I can be Crohn's okay
I'll give you funds um and by the way
I'm not to be flippant if you have
Crohn's you like you've no idea the hell
oh no no no this super plate we're
[ __ ] around everybody but I'm not
joking I changed my lifestyle stop
drinking start eating healthy and
smoking pot every day I think I can I
can manage Crohn's I think I got manage
crunch you just did a triathlon they
just did a triathlon yeah if I here's
the thing once I get a disease all I got
to do
clean my lifestyle up and I then I think
I can deal with it
okay two other diseases do you think you
could beat um hmm with some with your
eyes optimum optimum I could definitely
optim what is that a word better yeah I
could beat the gout easy
yeah goatee that's just shrimp you know
too much shrimp yeah not enough elbow
movement um but it affects millions
across the [ __ ] across the south
I grew up in the gout belt dude
everybody at Gao everyone's got gout
back in Tampa
dude red wine and [ __ ] Oh Sees shrimp
yeah you're fair your people owe half a
[ __ ] family's like crustaceans
barnacle on your back and like not
[ __ ] had a salty salad a couple years
ago and it's never been the same
it's crazy how salt just will get stuck
in your body dude when I like no joke
when I get my heaviest is like when I'm
on the road doing like if I do a theater
run I kind of balloon up because I'm
flying and partying every day like fly
perform party fly perform party and
that's when I balloon up and I'll come
home and I'll be like 240 and then just
all eat healthy for two days and I'll
drop 15 pounds immediately of just water
weight I'm just because that you eat
like [ __ ] in the airports you drinking
booze you're retaining water
you're on planes your ankles are below
yeah and then all of a sudden just I
always think like if I just built fences
I'd be in great shape really like just
built fences are like yeah really yeah
you don't think you'd be there cuz look
I used to work in that type of labor
force or not I mean it's so easy bro to
become this to do that [ __ ] naps in
the truck dude it's so easy to be that
dude okay I'm on you're right I'm wrong
I'm the Napper oh yeah what the [ __ ] am
i doing what the [ __ ] am I doing here I
got confident with Crohn's and I started
saying [ __ ] I could do no I couldn't do
that you're right you're right cuz I'm
the guy that if I was building fences
and they were like hey man we're gonna
burn one behind the house I'd be like
yeah I'm in I'm in next week you know
him in the back of a bed of a truck with
my head on the hammer going oh yeah yeah
yeah Bill's here let's get back to work
yeah it's so easy to book like all it
takes is one long lunch and next thing
you know you're that [ __ ] dude one
long lunch where they go in and they
pull in the store and the guy in front
of you your head your head chaperone
you're a guy yeah great so it grabs a 40
just a tall boy is a working he working
hard and suddenly if I can connect so
you know you're Rodney King never Rodney
King when he was on a celeb celeb rehab
and he worked for like some housing
company and he worked for a pool company
really in in Compton Terry basil worked
with him didn't he is that a comedian
yeah Harry basil that runs the Laugh
Factory they just show you no respect
what does that Rodney Dangerfield oh
yeah Ronnie Dangerfield I don't see I
don't drink before I go onstage and I
say Rodney King is the victor is one of
the victims yeah wait a 6 degree of
separation Rodney King from himself wait
Harry basil
Ronnie Dangerfield oh you're talking
about Rodney okay I get no respect I'm
sure he said that at some point during
the beating
you know what's crazy as my sister can't
even read but what does it have to do
with us right now hope you enjoyed that
video and you can watch another and you
can watch this one you can watch this
one different options different choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy to option
watch one this one against one